invited to the wedding and then as as
well are some of the family members from
the US side of the family so it's gonna
be a combination wedding family reunion
and sort of the creation of a new
generation and so in that respect the
book has had this life this afterlife I
should say that's been really
fascinating and I'm not exactly sure
where it's all gonna go but I think
there's there I think something more
will happen the other part about the
book that's really fascinating is that
he's involved in Ethiopia and I do think
that the way that he thought about an
ethiop he's the first African American
to go to Ethiopia the way he's thought
about in Ethiopia I I'm I'm curious to
see what he Theo pians think and that's
taking a little while to sort of pull it
out but I think that that will
eventually emerge as well Karl you know
you're anticipating my question it's
been a while at home since I've opened
the Kent J Loomis file
Kent Jameis is a Loomis cousin of mine
he is the subject of the most infamous
murder on my family tree and William
Ellis was his traveling companion to
Ethiopia Kent was a newspaper editor in
Parkersburg West Virginia but his
brother was Francis Loomis who was
assistant secretary of state under Teddy
Roosevelt and they traveled together and
Kent Loomis fell off the big was at
Queen Mary I can't remember the name of
the ship know it the bad things the like
the Hindenburg or something I don't know
it's that your as a German name I the
ends up washed ashore on the southern
coast of England they were carrying a
treaty to Ethiopia to be signed it's
been a while since I've seen the file
but after the death I assumed that Ellis
went on to have the treaty signed was he
in contact with Francis Loomis after
that about the death and in terms of the
difficulty of piecing together his life
what was the timeline for two years
afterward did death stick to him in some
sort of Specter fashion in terms of his
reputation and also I had also looked
into the colony I
a city in Mexico where they were taking
african-americans but it seems some of
those african-americans were unhappy
there and wanted to come back to the
United States would you address that as
well sure okay let me just give a little
background on that question so one of
the interesting chapters in the book is
that William Ellis is involved in
bringing the first u.s. treaty to
Ethiopia in the early 1900s and he he's
travelling on a steamship across the
Atlantic with the brother of the
Assistant Secretary of State and somehow
William Ellis has inserted himself into
the State Department in this case he's
passing sort of as a diplomat he has no
diplomatic background but somehow he's
attached himself to this diplomatic
mission and at some point the the
gentleman he's with his name is Kent
Loomis and he either is pushed or falls
off the steamship and his dead body
washes up on the shore of Great Britain
and there's a lot of controversy did
William Ellis push him over particularly
when people start to dig into his
background and realize he may not be
this Mexican figure that we thought he
was there may be something else and so
that that's the big whether he is a
murderer or not we've talked about
that's one of the big unresolved
mysteries in in the book the so I
believe afterwards William Ellis is
brought in to the State Department and
debriefed and he's debriefed also by
Teddy Roosevelt who's president at the
time and so he's and this of course
brings him notoriety and this is one of
the sort of subtle paradoxes of trying
to pass like this that only by obscuring
part of his background could he rise to
this sort of station of being involved
in American diplomacy at the same time
by becoming more visible he risk being
unmasked and his background being
revealed and so that's one of the the
real sort of paradoxes that he has to
navigate during this particular time
period and I've certainly all the
accounts you have is that he's extremely
nervous and anxious after this murder
accident takes place because there's the
risk of him being unmasked in a way and
then to follow up on the threat about
the which is some ways what I opened the
the questions about here about in 1895
when he he is behind bringing all these
african-americans to quarrel in Durango
the there is some of them there are
actually people in that area today who
still trace themselves back to that
original migration there are also some
of them who basically realized that even
though Mexico doesn't have segregation
basically they're going from being
sharecroppers in the u.s. to working on
ASEAN than Mexico it class-wise it's
really not much of a benefit one way or
the other and so some of them do end up
going back to the United States as well
I don't think he's able William Ellis
wasn't able to completely resolve all of
the challenges that African Americans
are facing during this time although I
think it's really there's tremendous
excitement and coverage in the United
States press particularly in the South
around this migration in the 1890s
because a lot of southerners I think on
some level realize that they're not
treating african-americans well and if
African Americans have an option that
there's the possibility that African
America thousands of African Americans
if not the majority of African Americans
might move to Mexico and this is one of
those alternative histories that's
really interesting to contemplate
it was a real enjoyable book about all
these different points Mexico the United
States Texas on that point is there any
other is that was this your first
connection to San Antonio in Texas and
is there any other interest in some
other of these Texas characters out
there that's a great question you know
the funny part
yeah I'm not from Texas and I had
actually when I thought about Texas
history I thought about of course the
Alamo and I had always thought well I'm
not sure I really want to be a Texas
historian but I shouldn't say that here
I'm sorry the but but there's a but here
which is important to get across so
initially I was just trying to trace
this character and I didn't know where
he was from and it went tracing him
backwards and of course eventually I
found myself in Victoria Texas you know
San Antonio and then Victoria Texas and
in retrospect I thought well of course
this makes sense where else would an
african-american be from in the 19th
century who would be really familiar
with Mexican culture and with Spanish
that really they could only be from from
from Texas on the academic level one of
the things that I'm really trying to get
across in the book is just the ways that
when we're thinking about the history of
slavery we need to bring it into the
history of the border much more than
we've done that one of the tensions in
Texas as a whole is that slavery is
blooming here in the 1850s so that the
family that that owned his his ancestors
was from the upper south from Kentucky
and they moved down to Victoria in the
1850s this is very common if you look at
almost all the slave owning families in
Victoria they're all from the upper
south from Kentucky you don't you can't
grow cotton in Kentucky you you can only
so they're all coming down to
participate in the cotton boom and as
cotton is booming here in in Texas as it
grows the more it grows the closer you
get to the border the closer you get to
the border the greater chance there is
that that slaves can escape and so it's
both an incredibly vibrant system it's
also a system that feels like it's under
assault because of the proximity of the
border and actually thousands of slaves
do escape across the border
to Mexico and so the larger object
lesson I became away from this
completely convinced that Texas history
is fascinating and just really I think
almost all of the most important and
interesting issues in American history
today are to be found in to be found in
Texas so I haven't actually figured out
what I'm gonna do next and maybe you can
give me some ideas about some of these
characters but I I do think that I've
become a convert to Texas history and
really it's it's important I had a
second minor question or side question
the the part where Vassar and the
Hemings I think it was it was a ronita
Hemings I can't quite remember did you
come across is that Hemings related to
the Jefferson Hemings group
there's even though she spells it with
two M's believed but what's that that
lineage so the the question here is at
one point one of the things I do in the
book as well as I try to bring in all
these other stories about passing that
are going on at the same time and one of
them has to do with Alice's sister goes
to Northwestern for year and then she's
thrown out because she's they discover
she's african-american and then I just
suppose this with a story of someone
from the I think her name is Anita
Hemmings who goes to Vassar and she
passes as Spanish so very similar thing
to what William Ellis is doing and she's
able to get her Vassar degree and
there's been a lot of debate about the
hemant most people think that actually
she is somehow related to the Hemings
family in fact you know Sally Hemings
original children a lot of them pass and
sort of disappear into white society so
they're very hard to trace but every of
the accounts that I've read all of them
suggested actually there is probably
some link between that Hemings family
and the Hemings family that Anita
Hemings was from
yes I want to know how did he make his
money how did it become a millionaire
and why was he not morning to unmask his
character yet he won't be a black
african-american or didn't want to be
Mexican or was a great question so the I
mean he's the first he's in theory the
first african-american on Wall Street
but it was you I it would have been
impossible to be openly black on Wall
Street in the in the you know late 19th
early 20th century so there's obvious
reasons for why you would want to keep
your background hidden the other thing
to keep in mind is he's married to a
white woman which was legal in New York
at the time but if you know you come to
your family in Texas it's illegal for
blacks and whites to be married so
there's both professional reasons and
personal reasons why he would want to
keep his background hidden it's also
advantageous because in many respects
what he serves as as a broker between
Mexicans in the US and so he Americans
want to invest in Mexico for all the
reasons I explained about the copper in
the oil most Americans know nothing
about Mexico which is sort of
illustrated by the fact that they
believe William Ellis was Mexican right
but then they're able to he is able to
serve as this link and the idea that
he's Mexican is very useful he actually
makes a lot of his so a lot of his money
is by setting up these these deals
between Americans and Mexicans he's also
involved in the biggest one as a water
company actually that's that set up this
is at the time when infrastructure is
being created both in Mexico and in the
u.s. around walk around water in the
ends of all the things to basically
privatize and make money out of it it's
actually a water system the the ending
Pablo don't give away too much of the
plot here but the the end point that's
kind of interesting is that he's doing
very well I'll leave it at this so I
don't give away all the plot but you
know he
okay well alright but he's very
connected to pour fuel Diaz who's
Porfirio Diaz who's the Mexican
president's last dictator and then the
Mexican Revolution comes along and they
throw out Porfirio Diaz and then the
question is well how do I make what is
my connection to be with Mexico when
Mexico is an you know revolutionary
turmoil and all the relationships that
I've formed with people in Porfirio
díaz's administration which were so
valuable all of a sudden those are
converted into liabilities because you
can be seen as a you know sort of an
exploiter if you're connected you
Porfirio the US
you knew Teddy Roosevelt organized the
Rough Riders about this time to 1895 or
soon and right over here to hotel many
oh yes right oh and bar have a drink and
it's theirs tell you Roosevelt's stuff
all down the aisle yep he might have
made contact there I don't I don't know
I do know William Oates did go to that
hotel to drink that was one of the
places I used to go yes they have good
mango ice cream too Bill Clinton had it
sent back to the White House so good and
then campaigned here for president I
think we have time for one more quick
question how should I be fast answer
fascinators heard was but we all know
the challenges of learning a different
language and I can see how he could
physically pass but the nuances of the
accent are very difficult to perfect did
he ever have any close calls with native
Mexicans because I cannot imagine him
passing on as easily they on that level
yeah that's a great question but the
thing is he actually didn't need to fool
the Mexicans as much because he mainly
he's trying to fool white white Texans
he's trying to fool Anglo's and so he
needs to be able to speak enough Spanish
so that they believe that he is a
Mexican often when he's in Mexico he
actually isn't pretending to be Mexican
because it's useful to be an American in
Mexico and so he's it's an ironically
I'm depending on which side of the
border he is he's a
Mexican in the United States but he's an
American often in in in in Mexico and so
the I do have letters that he's written
in Spanish which are written in really
beautiful fluent Spanish obviously this
is one of the frustrations of being a
historian like I don't have a tape
recording because there's no tape
recording technology so I don't know
what he spoke like and what his accent
would have been like what in in Spanish
because there's also regional variations
in Mexico in terms of what that regional
variation would have been a sort of you
know Mexico City Chilango accent versus
they think hanno accent from Texas is a
different thing and so how he negotiated
that as well I don't I don't know but
it's a great it's a great thing to think
about close calls like I didn't quite
fit the pattern but once in New York
well once in New York no he does
eventually not to give away one other
point but you know eventually in San
Antonio I'll say this in San Antonio he
gets caught and so eventually in San
Antonio one of the other reasons he
moves he leaves San Antonio and moves to
New York as he is caught in San Antonio
and the San Antonio City Directory used
to have a c4 colored after everyone who
was african-american and for many years
you would look in William Alice had no
see and then all of a sudden in the
1890s you see a see appear because of a
an incident I talked about in the book
and then after that he disappears from
San Antonio and I you don't see him
again until about a year later he pops
up in New York City so clearly he did
have he had more than a close call he
had you know he was caught eventually
but that made him much more careful when
he was in New York in New York City that
is all the time we have but you can
continue a conversation with Karl he'll
be signing books right outside the
library please join me in thanking him
for this wonderful conversation
okay
and now from the San Antonio Book
Festival author Jeff Guin reports on Jim
Jones the cult leader responsible for
the Jonestown Massacre well welcome
everyone the name of this session is a
story behind the kool-aid Jim Jones and
Peoples Temple my name is Gilbert Garcia
I'm the Metro columnist at the San
Antonio express-news and I'm really
pleased to be here today I wanted before
we get started I wanted to also mention
to you that we're gonna make sure that
we leave about 10 minutes toward the end
for for questions from the audience and
if you have a question please go to that
mic there in the center of the room and
also after the session is over if you
want to get your book signed by Jeff
Gwynn the place to go is there's a
Barnes & Noble book tent outside so
that's that's where you'll go to get
that done so we're gonna get started
person to my right is Jeff Gwynn he's a
best-selling award-winning author and
former journalist based in Fort Worth
and he's a member of the Texas literary
Hall of Fame
he's written 19 books over the years and
he's proven himself equally adept at
writing fiction and nonfiction those
books include Manson the life and times
of Charles Manson go down together the
true untold story of Bonnie and Clyde
and the last gun fight the real story of
a shootout the OK Corral and how it
changed the American West his new book
the road to Jonestown Jim Jones and
Peoples Temple is the definitive account
of the life of one of the most
fascinating and controversial religious
figures of the 20th century and how the
idealistic socially conscious movement
that Jim Jones created came to a
horrific end in Guyana now Jeff you and
I talked a little bit the other day
about the fact that when you when you
write a nonfiction book you tend to pick
an error that you're interested in
writing and then you decide what figure
or what event from that period
you think maybe kind of helps to defines
that era or would be a really good sort
of entree into into looking at that
period before this you wrote it about
the 60s wrote about Charles Manson
in looking at the 70s you decided to
focus on Jim Jones and Peoples Temple
what was it about him and that movement
that you thought kind of a captured that
era one of the things that I think is
important is if we're going to be
writing about a time in American history
we want to pick an iconic individual or
event that folks will remember from that
time sometimes it can be a joyful event
the book that I'm working on now for
Simon & Schuster doesn't involve death
that it involves America right after the
turn of the 20th century when inventions
were coming into full flower in the
country was just aghast at all these
great things moving them into the modern
times but when I finished the manson
book which was really about the 1960s in
america and i know i'm the only person
in the room that's old enough to
remember the 60s I was there the rest of
you will have to take my word I wanted
then to look at what happens next in
America in the 1960s the country almost
comes apart the social schisms seem so
vast that can we ever be a united people
again and I think many Americans came
out of the 60s suspicious of government
of big business and even of the church
so I wanted to find out for myself and
hopefully for readers how did the 60s
segue into the 70s and I decided there's
just two events from the 1970s that that
everybody pretty much remembers now and
the first was Watergate and I looked at
that and I thought there have been over
400 books
I don't think there's anything new that
I can bring to this and the other great
part of American history that we all
know a phrase we've all used don't drink
the kool-aid and yet it wasn't kool-aid
many of the people that day did not
choose to drink it
they were held down and forcibly
injected the word for that is murder and
most amazingly of all Jim Jones and
Peoples Temple was never a freak show we
think today most of us that oh it was
just some clearly lunatic leader and a
bunch of mindless folks who follow him
into certain doom and nothing could be
further from the truth so the purpose of
this book there's two number one is to
look at how American history is evolving
nothing happens in a vacuum how do the
50s the 60s lead into the 70s make it
possible for someone like Jim Jones to
emerge and second who were these people
who followed him what reason did they
have and of course as it turns out many
of them were amazingly talented
intelligent socially conscious people
who were trying very much to help bring
about a better world so those were the
two things were trying to get at in the
book and I'm very grateful to the San
Antonio Book Festival and for Gilbert
for giving us this chance to talk about
that for a little bit
well along those lines you know whether
the kind of the contradictions with Jim
Jones that kind of fascinates me is on
one level you know he grew up in a small
Indiana town and he was kind of a
religious prodigy I mean he he could
quote biblical passages you know but by
memory and he would run from one church
service to another as Jeff it talks
about the book he'd go from one church
service to another on a Sunday to try to
catch as many as he could
and yet there was also the side to him
where he said he said this late I think
in his life and his wife was quoted as
saying basically the same thing that he
never really believed in God that he was
that really that he used religion as a
way to infiltrate the you know I guess
maybe to - he wanted to to spread the
cut the concept of socialism and he used
religion as a way to do it and I guess I
my question is what is your sense and it
was obviously he understood a lot about
what really effect that religion had on
people and he had hits read the Bible
and he knew so much about it
what do you think his belief system was
I think that like most of us Jim Jones
had an evolving belief system there's no
way we can ever look into anybody's
heart and say this person definitely
believes what he's saying now or this
person is making it all up
to understand Jones we have to look at
his whole life not just the notorious
last few years that we all remember so I
want you to imagine that you're a little
boy growing up in Lynn Indiana which is
up in the northwest part of the state
it's rural and your father is a very
disabled World War one vet who's been
gassed and can hardly talk and hardly
speak your mother is an outspoken rebel
who believes that she has lived hundreds
of lives and was a great woman in a
previous life and that was ordained to
her in a dream that she should give
birth to the greatest man who ever lived
and would change the world
so here he is growing up in this little
tiny town where religion is the basis of
existence everybody goes to church less
than a thousand people five churches in
town and here's this little boy who
spends ten minutes with the Nazarenes
and then he wants to run over and have
some more time with the Methodists and
don't forget the Baptist are just around
the corner
and yet he's also being told at home
that this is your latest incarnation
you're going to do great things and then
Jones when he decides to enter the
ministry does it in Indianapolis and
this is one of the most segregated
cities in America in the 1940s early
1950s they have laws passed that seem
benign things like nobody can buy a
house in the neighborhood unless the
majority of the homeowners in that block
agreed to the sale and how does that let
black people buy into a white
neighborhood
it doesn't Jim Jones started his
ministry in a little storefront Church
in Indianapolis with a few older black
people who remembered crosses being
burned on lawns for whom Jim Crow was
every bit as real as Jesus Christ and he
did amazing things within 10 years Jim
Jones virtually single-handed integrated
one of the most racist major cities in
America and he's doing this 15 years
before the Civil Rights Act makes it
mandatory I have talked to old people in
Indianapolis who say that without Jim
Jones their lives would have been
worthless and they don't care what he
did later did he believe in God then I
can't tell you what I can tell you is
that in the name of God he accomplished
the kinds of great things that would if
he had been hit by a car and killed in
the 1950s would make him remember today
as one of the heroes of the early civil
rights movement and he would have
deserved it later he's saying I never
believed in God at all I only used it to
bring people in to follow me and to get
a social play
for we talked about him we remember only
the awful end but let's also consider
the fact this is a man who also in his
early career did more good than almost
anybody else you're ever going to meet
he was a contradiction then he's a
contradiction now yeah and and you know
one of the things that's that's
interesting is you said he was doing so
many things as far as social justice he
was taking care of the elder they had I
think he didn't his wife had a nursing
home several several yeah and they did I
mean there was so much good work that
they did and I don't think they were
real too conscious about about money I
mean he tended to whatever money he had
early on at least he tended to use for
hire purposes well but even early on you
know you get the sense from from your
book that the the darker qualities that
would eventually prove to be his undoing
that you could see them in there there
there was a paranoia a possessiveness
that that came out and one of the
stories that that fascinated me with we
talked the other day about this was his
wife had a cousin who they took in and
was living with them and he was I think
the cousin was like 11 years old Jim was
only in his early 20s at the time and
Jim wanted to adopt the boy and he the
boy didn't want to didn't want that and
Jim got furious and angry and it became
a really ugly situation and and in some
ways Jim when I look at like letters
that you that you quote where he's
writing if one person was gonna leave
the church this is what he was still in
Indiana and sixties he would write these
you know long letters and get very upset
it almost reminded me of the performer
who has you know 5,000 cheering fans in
the audience but all they can focus on
is that one person in the crowd with
their arms crossed who's you know who's
browning it Jim seemed to obsess about
there was some deep sense of rejection
that he had to I mean do you think that
was correctly there was something in his
nature where he just he couldn't handle
anyone leaving or anyone rejecting him
the reason we look at a person's life a
demagogue like Jim Jones we look at the
whole life as we look back to see what
clues are there of what's to come and
what you had was a man who was always
possessive of everything if you were a
member of his church that meant that you
belong to him forever as far as he was
concerned but he carried that into other
aspects of his life I mean I have talked
to his high school sweetheart
you know if you date Jim Jones by God
you're his and he meant it if one person
when he had thousands of followers
filling an auditorium but his rule was
you couldn't get up and leave
he had scheduled bathroom breaks every
hour or so but if someone had to get up
if let's say someone's cellphone had
gone off in the middle of a program he
would have called down the power of the
Lord ma'am you don't have to worry about
that we're friendlier here but the whole
the whole idea of Jim Jones was that he
did these great things and yet at the
same time he's looking always to build
himself a basis for power and influence
he wants to be the one in charge
his cousin gene who grew up with him
right down the block
told me stories of how during World War
two Jimmy is 11 12 years old all the
other kids in Lynn Indiana all the boys
there Allied soldiers you know they're
Patton or they're Montgomery in there
they're fighting they're fake Wars and
winning Jimi is fascinated with the
Nazis he loves the way Hitler has the
crowds hanging on every word he's sort
of the middle-aged cousin and they're a
bunch of Jones kids in town there's like
25 and he forces all the younger Joneses
to march for him under his command and
they have to goose-step if they don't
goose-step right he's got his switch and
he's slamming their legs with a switch
and did that till their mothers found
out and he's fascinated when Hitler
commits suicide that this is Hitler
thumbing his nose at the enemies
surrounding him that when this great
leader came to the end and it was going
to be all over would not give his
enemies the satisfaction of capturing
him do you have any wonder why the hair
stood up on my arms when I'm hearing
these stories if you really want to
understand a controversial figure I
promise you look back in their lives
you're going to see the pattern well you
know eventually he moved the people's
temple from Indiana to California along
the way in the early sixties he thought
about setting up a colony in Brazil he
spent a couple of years there and I
think he was I think he hated being away
because he didn't want anybody else to
be to take over services his church
because he yeah he was very competitive
and he had to be in control but that
that didn't work out he ended up in
California in the 70s and to give you a
sense of the situation that he was in I
mean he was he had become so politically
powerful there then you had George
Moscone the the the mayor of San
Francisco made him chair of the the City
Housing Authority in the mid 70s in 1976
there was a political event when Jimmy
Carter is running for president and he
speaks there with Rosalyn Carter and I
think he pretty much stole the show that
Pharisee and I and from I think he had a
private dinner with Rosalyn Carter later
he there were letters of the kind of
letters for recommendation written on
his behalf by Rosalyn Carter by Walter
Mondale who at this point had become the
vice president so he's a person who had
a lot of political power and influence
but at the same time there was you know
he had become very controversial they
were starting to be articles and they
were certainly be scrutiny of some of
the questionable behavior that was
happening there so it was in this
context that he decided to move to Ghana
right and this is if you can talk a
little bit about what what the situation
was and what his thinking was what he
was trying to create in moving the
People's Temple to the jungles of South
America well let's take ourselves back
to the 1960s in America and again I know
most of you will have to use your
imagination so bear with me
Peoples Temple first in Indianapolis
and then in California gains our
reputation for doing great positive
things they have drug treatment programs
when drugs this is the first time it's a
rampant disease in America they have not
only free restaurants where if you're
hungry you can go in and be fed no
questions asked and then after you've
had your meal you're taken to their
clothing store where you can pick out
clothes no charge they even went so far
is for ghetto kids to pay to send them
to college full ride these are kids who
otherwise the only education they would
have gotten would have been on the
streets in the riots that we're going on
in America at that time People's Temple
is taking them placing them in school
paying for everything giving them a
chance at life is it any wonder that
politicians want to attach themselves to
this particularly let's think in San
Francisco in the 1960s and the cities
changing for years the power structure
has been the business leaders downtown
they're the ones that make the decision
everybody's going to come to San
Francisco because tourism is going to be
our big industry and we want the
tourists who come to see all the great
stuff we wanted to see Chinatown you
know we want them to look at the
beautiful Bay the Golden Gate Bridge we
don't want them seeing anything
unsightly in San Francisco
there is a sizable black ghetto and the
powers that be cooler than hell begin a
reclamation project where the city is
going to if it has to take control of
all the land and it's going to knock
down all these unsightly slums gonna put
in some freeways in their place so that
tourists can get in and out of town
quicker
and then maybe we'll put up some nice
shopping areas you know souvenir stands
so suddenly you have this sizable
minority group they're being
dispossessed get the hell out of here
we don't want you they have no political
voice and suddenly here comes this man
and his church first of all saying all
of you matter you're important if you
join us you will get complete respect we
will help you educate your children so
they don't have to live lives in the
ghetto and we will work together and we
will improve your lives Jones always
bragged about Peoples Temple that it is
a church where you get something now
other you know other ministers would say
you know everything in life you put up
with some day you're going to go to
heaven it will be wonderful Jim Jones
said if you're in this church we're
going to improve things now but they
didn't do it
confrontationally anybody here ever here
are the Black Panthers well I promise
you in California in the 1960s early
1970s they caused fear they were
organized they didn't back down they
were scary black people and now you get
People's Temple which is a mixed-race
congregation blacks whites Hispanics
people mingling together as equals and
they want to get involved publicly by
doing positive things George Moscone
running for mayor of San Francisco
knowing he's got big business against
him is only going to win if he can
gather all the discarded parts of the
population make a new coalition get them
out to vote who is he going to go to who
can do that but Jim Jones and Jim Jones
not only delivers he not only gets his
people voting he lends the Greyhound
buses the fleet of buses belonging to
people's temple - the Mosconi campaign
so you can pick up Moscone voters
anywhere in town even if there's no
other transportation get him to a voting
booth Jim Jones jr. who was so wonderful
contributing to this book sat in on a
meeting where Jones explained to
mosconi's people you've got a lot of
registered San Francisco voters living
in Los Angeles let's send a couple buses
down there on Election Day bring him
back George Moscone wins by a scant few
thousand votes any wonder who made it
possible and who expects quid pro quo
now that's how Jim Jones would
accomplish things not by tearing down
not by threatening it's look at all the
positive things we can do together and I
have to ask you you are intelligent
folks right your readers you're socially
committed if there was someone in San
Antonio in those tumultuous years who
said I really can bring people together
and we're gonna do fine things we're not
going to tear down we're gonna build up
pretty persuasive don't you think that
was Jim Jones you know the other side of
that is the the the extra incident Rissa
teased that started to come out over
time and and you talk about some of the
services that he was doing later were
you know he would start talking about
how he had been annexed he was an
extraterrestrial and his life on other
planets and things like that and I was
fascinated reading this and and as you
know you pointed out it's it's really
unfair to his followers that some
there's something often depicted as kind
of mindless sheep you know following him
but I
I did find myself wondering you know how
it was that he would he would sometimes
to go on these tangents that his
followers were willing to stick with him
and I'm guessing a lot of it was if they
had been with him for so long and they'd
seen his good work and they had gotten
used to some of some of the stranger
things that would sometimes come from
him but you also talk about how in the
early 70s his his use of amphetamines
and tranquilizers
start to get out of control and I'm
wondering how much of the the the dark
side that we think of with Jim Jones was
there and was with and it was heading in
that direction anyway and how much was
fueled by his drug use in the 70s Jim
Jones is always a megalomaniac he always
believes at least to some extent that
it's been preordained that he would be
great he always lies he is really
unthinking and cruel to his wife he's
selfish as he's accomplishing these
great things as he gets more attention
he is also getting less criticism from
those around him when he does odd things
when he maybe overdoses on the
amphetamines he says he has to take
because he needs to be awake 20 out of
24 hours a day to get so many great
things done it makes it easy to say well
that's Jim he performs faith healings
that her fake as the day gets long and
if you read this book I think one of the
interesting sections you might find is
how these faith healers actually do
produce these cancers that they take
from people's bodies hint chicken parts
he sexually abused many of his followers
haven't we all seen then and today
examples of men in power who abuse that
with women it's disgusting and it's
cyclical as he began more and more to
become famous to achieve what he wanted
he began less and less to worry about
what impression he might be giving in
private for the way that he's acting
members of the church who disobey Him
can suffer terrible beatings
in front of everybody else he has sex
with the wife of one of his closest
followers they have a child there's a
whole lawsuit there's all kinds of legal
battles going on over custody of the
child so what he's Jim Jones he gets
what he wants
it was inevitable with all the bad
things he was doing and please
understand just because of all the great
accomplishments that doesn't in any way
negate the horrible things he's doing at
some point the media's going to catch up
with him and when they do Jones does two
things first of all he starts claiming
hang on up this is a phrase that was
used back then I'm sure no one here is
familiar with it fake news
they're making it up they can't prove it
and as they started to prove it he would
continue saying they haven't proved it
at all until finally that he got too bad
and there was a foreign farm settlement
in Guyana that Peoples Temple had
started and Jones was going to escape
there it was going to happen demagogues
in any form even if they're promising
their followers we're gonna make this a
better world at some point lead them to
doom and one last point I'd like to make
quickly if you don't mind we're talking
about why people would follow him well
okay we know all these great things that
are happening but there's all the real
call eccentricity zuv Jim Jones
how do you forgive that one of the
members of Peoples Temple in fact one of
the few remaining survivors of that
terrible day November 18th 1978 told me
this story it's like the Frog and a pot
of water if you drop a frog in a pot of
boiling water it's going to hop out
right away but if you sit the frog in a
pot of lukewarm water and turn up the
heat
litora but little by little it will
almost allow itself to be boiled to
death please don't think when you read
about crazy Jim Jones at the end that he
was always exactly that way it was
incremental it happened over a number of
years and again the difference - between
him and other demagogues and followers
demagogues gained their following by
creating enemies out there if I'm the
only one they will all say who can fix
the problems today there's all these
people that let's take this side of the
room no offense these are the people who
already have everything they want what
you've got if you don't follow me
they're going to get everything you own
they're going to take it away they
create that tension the members of
People's Temple did not join because
they thought they were going to get
something they gave up everything they
owned joyfully the idea being they were
going to set an example of a group where
everybody is the same everyone is
treated alike and that example will be
so wonderful that the rest of the world
will see it and adopt it will finally
have a world where race doesn't matter
where money doesn't matter so they were
getting into this because they thought
ultimately for all the crap Jim Jones is
doing on the side he's still the one
who's going to lead us to this great
moment they did it out of generosity and
not selfishness now you write in the
book about once they got to guy on a if
the I hadn't thought of it from this
angle but now he's living amongst his
followers 24/7 they're really seeing
things that maybe they hadn't seen to
that to that degree when they were in
California and of course in the events
leading up to the the mass suicide you
had Congressman Leo Ryan from California
visited he brought a group to see what
was going on some people wanted to leave
with him and then some Jones followers
ambushed them and shot and killed some
of the people who were true were at an
airstrip Jones responded by then
basically ordering this this mass
suicide what what was the as you said
their people had now started to see a
different side and maybe then they had
seen before when they were in California
what was what was the the the thinking
if we can kind of generalize about his
followers in those final hours and final
days before that tragic event now
consider the fact that you've got 900
people living in the middle of one of
the densest most dangerous jungles in
the world I've been there I had to sort
of cut my way in with a machete I don't
advise you to do that it's not fun they
are out there in the middle of the
jungle and they have carved out 800
acres of a working farm all these years
since the government of Guyana has tried
to do the same thing it's never
succeeded only once a preacher from
America with a number of followers most
of whom had never even mowed a lawn they
did it that's leadership
this was Jim Jones's last chance to be
on the world stage and to prove that
under his leadership you could have a
socialist situation that the rest of the
world would want to follow the people
following him were up at 6:00 every
morning there working out in the fields
laboring until 5:00 at night their meals
are skimpy in the evenings they have to
go to a pavilion and listen to Jim Jones
preach for another four or five hours
they're getting maybe three or four
hours sleep a night they are physically
and mentally exhausted he has taken
their passports no one has any money he
says if you want to leave I guess you
can but we're not paying your way first
of all you'd have to find your way
through miles and miles of impenetrable
jungle and if you do get back to
civilization you have no passport or
money a group of concerned relatives in
America they've got family living in
Jonestown claim that their relatives are
being held against their will it's a
slave camp congressman Leo Ryan in
California goes to investigate taking
him with him members of the media they
get to Jonestown and lo and behold a few
dozen people want to leave out of over
900 that's all the congressman is
astonished so maybe this isn't a slave
camp maybe most of the people do want to
be here so he says he'll take the ones
who want to leave take them home media
takes their picture does some interviews
when that group is about to leave some
of the leaders in Jonestown tell tell
Jim John sets that's pretty good
you know we're actually we've come away
well on this every one of those people
belong to Jim Jones and if a doesn't
leave today
who knows how many more are leaving now
that this one congressman has gotten in
here more people are coming it's over
under his orders men follow the
congressman the media the defectors to a
little airstrip they opened fire five
are murdered dozen more injured Jim
Jones calls his followers to the
pavilion announces that the congressman
has been killed it wasn't what Jones
wanted but it happened because these
people loved him so much they just did
it
the Army's coming in there's nothing
left we have to make a gesture and so he
wants everyone to line up the children
first the infants they're going to go
over it's going to be simple it isn't
cyanide poisoning is horrible they died
convulsive deaths some people didn't
want to do it he's got a tape recorder
going the whole time you can hear the
tape ultimately over 900 people are dead
he's made his gesture just like the
little boy in Lynn who thought Hitler
did a fine thing that's the horror and
the tragedy is that so many decent
well-meaning people died and so we learn
from this we hope well we've got about
10 minutes left we're gonna take some
questions from the audience if you have
a question just go to that mic there in
the center of the room and please we're
really counting on you we need some
really good question yes sir
great I can remember exactly when that
occurred in November 78 I was in my car
and you turn on the radio do you
remember where you were and what
happened can you can you tell us all
about and in it how all you're assured
thank you well when when this happened
in 1978 I was living in Arlington Texas
working for a non-profit I had been a
school teacher I taught seventh grade
English and I caught myself thinking how
could I ever explain this
two kids because it was just so
overwhelming like everyone else the
horror of it was so vast that was all I
could really think about at the time and
I could only think what kind of fools
would have followed a man like this
that's something I thought right up to
the point I started meeting them and
realized they weren't fools but for
people my age and I'm 65 I remember
three things above all else in my life
when Kennedy was assassinated I remember
Jim Jones and Peoples Temple and I
remember 9/11 and these I think are the
three great tragedies of modern American
history I wanted to understand this one
better I hope in reading my book maybe
that will happen for you folks too yes
sir
Jeff I'd like to stray a little bit off
in the particulars of this book if I may
my question is in reading your books it
seems that your writing embodies the
single greatest trait that a writer
could possess and that is that each
sentence compels you to the next
sentence and the next sentence and the
next sentence and I'd like to know who
your influences were as a writer when I
was eight I decided to be a writer
because I read my first book by John
Steinbeck and I thought someday I'm
going to be able to do that and my
Steinbeck apex was travels with Charlie
if any of you have read it here's this
fascinating book about a man who gets in
a truck with his dog drives all around
meets interesting people and actually
can write a book about it I thought I
want to get in on that
I never obviously became as great a
writer is John Steinbeck but I will tell
you this over my writing desk in Fort
Worth when I sold my first story to a
newspaper for $30 I used that money to
take a picture of John Steinbeck I had
cut out of a magazine when I was 10 and
I had it framed and that picture is
above my writing desk and I look at it
every morning when I'm starting to work
so that's that's where I got it going
from Thank You John Steinbeck yes ma'am
hello so I haven't read the book yet but
I plan on doing it and when you talk
about Jones attachment issues do you
believe they arose from his family
background or do you believe he had
abandonment issues as a young child or
what do you personally believe came
about to these attachment issues he had
if we're gonna talk about the bad
influence on Jim Jones first of all I
have to say Inlet with my last two books
I've come to the reluctant conclusion
that it's actually possible to be born
bad enough that your life will turn out
in some horrific way but Jim Jones had a
mother who was so alienated from
everyone else and she's got this kid in
a little ramshackle home every night
telling him about how the world is
picking on her and on their family and
is out to get them it's always the
bosses you've got to fight back I know
because I had the vision before your
birth that you are going to be the great
man and so he's hearing this when he's
three four or five years old and he's in
a small community where the whole idea
is everybody's supposed to be the same
that's the ambition he's the one person
besides mama who's a woman ostracized
because my god she smokes in public and
she doesn't wear dresses here you've got
this little kid going out there and from
the beginning thinking he's different
he's got to he wants to bring attention
to himself that's where it goes back to
I truly believe
yes sir a Jeff I'm just curious guy
watched a documentary last night holy
hell it was another kind of cultish kind
of place and I what I was wondering
about is because as a Reggie or Manson
book is how did that affect you in your
faith like to me faith is one of the
ways a lot of us keep our sanity but
when I look at these things and it seems
like I don't know I just wondered how it
affected your faith looking at these
things if my faith is troubled by some
of the people I write about then my
faith is strengthened by some of the
people I meet when I'm writing in
writing about Jonestown and Peoples
Temple with some of the survivors who
spent the rest of their lives
trying to rebuild knowing them and
seeing the courage they've shown that
restores any faith that I might lose
when I think about Jones so yes
sometimes it can be shaken but it also
gets reinforced yes sir I was wondering
what you thought the difference between
communism and socialism is sure with
communism as it was understood in those
days that's when the government said you
have to live this way it is forced
socialism would be more of a choice by
society to have certain traditions in
certain ways of doing things so the
differences between choice and being
ordered that's the way it was looked at
then there can be all kinds of different
definitions but I'm talking about the
broadest ones under which People's
Temple presented themselves as
socialists at that time we just got a
couple of minutes left and I apologize
for throwing the statute was so little
time but what do you have a sense of
what Jones if his life hadn't taken the
dark turn what he'd be doing politically
now he was still alive I mean you talk
about demagogues and we've experienced a
few I that's a fair question
all all religious leaders all
politicians to a censor demagogues
they're trying to create a sense of
urgency vote for me join my church
Jones towards
and of his time in San Francisco and
this scares the hell out of me had
started talking about public office in
the way was saying Reverend Jones says
he doesn't yet have time but you've got
to remember he's a again he's a national
figure and he's around vice presidents
first lady's governors and certainly his
thinking he's greater than they are I'll
tell you this if Jim Jones had wanted to
go into politics
he'd have been good at it and he
wouldn't have aimed low and if you say
oh that's ridiculous no one like Jim
Jones who had no political experience
who was only a performer and claimed
only he could save the world you think
he could be elected president the United
States never hacker what a fool you are
I think we need to study the life of Jim
Jones so we can learn lessons that would
be helpful to us in making our choices
today thank you well thank you thank you
Jeff Winn and thank you for coming
you
[Applause]